Red one we're coming at you is the movie event of the holiday season Santa Claus has been kidnapped You're gonna help us find you can't trust this guy. He's on the list. It's a naughty Lister naughty Lister Dwayne Johnson We got snowman Chris Evans, you might just go back to the car. Let's save Christmas I'm not gonna say that say it. All right Let's see Christmas. There it is. Only in theaters November 15th. The Sephora Savings Event is here. World in my hand, I'll take this and that.
And that. Ooh, and this. Oh, it's true. Find everything you want on sale at the Sephora Savings Event. It only happens twice a year and it's on now through November 11th. Find brands like Rare Beauty, Glow Recipe, Valentino, K18, and more, all for less. Shop at Sephora today. Limitations apply. Must be a beauty insider.
See terms at sephora.com for complete details. Hello, everyone. Welcome to Second Drink. Yes, every Monday we are rerunning the Office Ladies Rewatch episodes in order from the beginning and today we are taking a second drink of the pilot. I re-listened to this episode and I thought we killed it. I really did. I thought we did an amazing job. I was legitimately impressed. I mean there is a ton of great info in this. I know. I re-listened too and I was like damn. Okay. But we did go digging around and we
found a few more things we could share. I'll start. I have a background catch. Oh yeah? There is a kitten calendar at reception. Pam has a kitten calendar on the wall. I feel like Angela and Pam could have been friends if not for maybe everything. Okay, I have another one. Last week we had our interview with Alison Jones. Yes.
And when I was digging around preparing for that interview, I found my audition materials. I had saved them. And in those materials, there was a talking head that I had to do for my audition, and it reveals how Roy proposed to Pam. And I know we shot it, it did not make it in the original episode,
but I believe it is in the Peacock Superfan episode of the pilot, but I thought I could read it. Do it. All right, here it is. This is what I said. Yeah, we're engaged. Roy proposed on Valentine's Day. Well, he didn't actually do it in person.
He did it through one of the little Valentine's ads in the paper. It must have cost money by the word because it only said, Roy, love, Pam, marriage, question mark. Which I think is great because it's not every day that you get something that's both romantic and thrifty. And that's really what everyone wants. Every young girl's dream is romance plus thrifty.
I know. Oh man. Well listen, we all know Kevin's philosophy. Why say lot word when few word do trick? It's true and look at all the ladies Kevin has. Exactly. Incidentally, that talking head was taken from the British office. It was in the episode training day. I'm glad we didn't include it.
Yeah, I don't think we need that much information about Pam's unhappiness yet. Yeah, I like some of the backstory that we created for Pam and Roy. I love the stuff we're going to find out about him and his brother leaving her at the hockey game and about the jet skis and all that. So I like that stuff a little better. Well, here's what I'm bringing to Second Drink today. When we originally broke down the pilot, Jenna, you talked about a fun deleted scene where Dwight is distracted by the boom operator's microphone. Yes.
It was one of those early talking heads where Ken Quapus, our director, would just sit us down and start asking us a series of questions to get us talking in character. We didn't play it, but I thought it'd be fun for you guys to hear. No, no, can you move it? Is that all right? Can you make that work? That's fine. You don't need to even... That's fine. We'll keep it...
I'm sorry, it makes me nervous. But it's what we need to capture what you're saying as clearly as possible. I understand. It's in a blind spot. Because I'm trained in several martial arts and one of them includes an awareness that the masters bring of anything on all sides of you. It could be behind you or whatever. This is directly in a blind spot so I'm trained to respond negatively to something right above my head.
This now, I have an eye on, you see? It's in my periphery, and if I needed to block it, attack it, stop it somehow, I could come right out. I mean, I know you're doing your job, but I'm doing my job. What is his job in this moment? To like karate kick the boom operator's microphone? His job in life is to be aware of any unexpected, I guess, danger. Correct.
Yes. He is my chihuahua. He is biscuit. Yes, yes. Well, I'm really glad you played that clip because I wished we had played it during our breakdown of the pilot. I also love hearing Ken. Yes, me too.
Well, like I said, I really enjoyed re-listening to this episode, so maybe we should get to it, our second drink of the pilot. And be sure to join us this Wednesday for Office Ladies 6.0. It is all about Michael Scott. That's right, you all wrote in and wanted to know more about Michael Scott's family of origin. Well, I uncovered some good stuff and I can't wait to share. She won't even tell me. She's keeping it a surprise.
You have to wait till Wednesday. We'll see you Wednesday, but for now, here is the pilot of The Office. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office re-watch podcast just for you.
Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office Ladies. Hello, everybody. This is Jenna Fischer. Hi, this is Angela Kinsey. And this is our very first Office Ladies podcast.
I'm so excited, Jenna. I'm so excited. I'm a little bit freaking out. I'm freaking out. We hope you guys like it. We have been working really hard. This is a dream we've had for years of getting to work together again.
Yes. Because we became best friends while working on The Office together. We did. We ate lunch together every single day. Every single day. And I think the hardest part for me about the show ending was not getting to see you every day, Angela.
Me too. It is so special to get to work with your best friend every day. Yes. What a gift. That was the thing. You know, Steve Carell told us, and I just love this moment so much, he said to Jenna and I, no matter what happens with the show,
this is what you two will take from it. And he was so right. It's true. And we've been trying to figure out some way that we could work together again ever since. So here it is. It's a dream realized. It's a dream realized. We thought, what a better time. The 15-year anniversary is coming out. And I had like three Rubbermaid bins of photos in my shed.
And I was going through them and I was getting really nostalgic. And I was telling Jenna about it. I was like, Jenna, we had such an amazing time on that show. I mean, it just was one of the joys of my life. And you know, I hadn't watched most of the episodes since they aired. So this has been a real treat for me to go back and finally rewatch them.
Me too, and it's so good, you guys. I mean, it really- We've become kind of nerdy fans of our own show. We've become nerdy fans. And here's the thing. When we were filming it, you're kind of living and breathing the day of it. And I watched them all when they aired.
But now I'm watching them just as like an audience. And it's just so fun. It's been so much fun. And I feel like here it is. It's the office bringing us back together again. Yes. It's so special. It's so special. It's so special.
Okay, we're geeking out. So we're geeking out. And listen, you guys, we just want you to know, we're so excited that you're gonna join us in this journey and rewatch every week with us, listen to us, chitty chat about being best friends. And there are gonna be times that maybe we forget something, right?
Or we miss something. Or we miss something. Because we're not experts, we just, we're on the show. We're on something. Because we're not experts. We just were on the show. We're on the show and we love the show. You are actually probably the expert. You guys are the experts. So please watch along with us, send in questions, and let's just rewatch it together.
And we're gonna start from the beginning. We're gonna start with the pilot and we're gonna watch it in order. Oh my gosh, that brings us to the pilot. This is it. This is it. That's what we're gonna talk about today. Okay, so just so you know how Jenna works, you guys, she has like her list, she prints out,
she has her laptop, she has two notepads, and then I just bring a whole bunch of colored note cards with a Sharpie. That sort of paints a picture of how we process information. It is. I'm a little bit more, I don't know. I don't know, Jenna, you're more organized. It's okay. You can say it. And you're more colorful.
Oh, well, okay. Well, I guess I'm going to take that as a compliment. All right. So let's get started. Let's get started. The pilot. We're going to talk about the pilot. This is season one, episode one. This episode is written by Ricky Gervais, Stephen Merchant, and Greg Daniels, and directed by Ken Quapis. Let's start with a synopsis. I think that's a good place to start.
Great. All right. So in this episode, we're going to meet the employees of Dunder Mifflin Paper Company as introduced by their manager, Michael Scott. This is just a normal day at an ordinary, like, workplace, just people living their lives. Yes.
A pilot episode is usually introducing each of the characters and also the convention of the show. And in this case, the convention of the show is that this is a documentary. Right. This is the world you're going to see every day. Is this paper company? Yes.
Now, I had an idea. What? I think for each episode, we should have something called fast facts. What are you even talking about? This sounds crazy. A fast fact. What is a fast fact? Okay, stay with me here.
A fast fact is a fact about that episode. Mm-hmm. And then we talk about it. Not necessarily fast. Wait, do I have to talk quickly? No. Here's an example of a fast fact. Okay. The show, The Office, is actually an adaptation
of a British show of the same name, The Office. That's right. It was called The Office. It was written by Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant. It's fantastic. It is amazing. I was a huge fan of it before I even went to the audition for the American version of The Office.
Same. I had watched the entire series and then I got a phone call that they were doing an American version and asking me to audition for the receptionist. And I about pooped myself. Yeah, yes. I was excited and nervous because I loved the British version so much. And I was like, oh, I hope they do it justice. And I mean, come on.
Years later, I think we did it. Well, we got a lot of critical attention when we were making the pilot and not a lot of love because people really thought we were going to mess it up. That's right. People were worried because this, the British show was award-winning, critically acclaimed. It's considered still to this day, one of the greatest television comedies ever made. And it deserves all of that.
And it is. Because it is amazing. Yes. And so there was a lot of pressure on us when we were going in to make this. And something that I think is often said is that we did a shot by shot remake of the British pilot, which is not true. That is not true.
It is not a shot for shot remake, but we did use their script as a template. And there are some adjustments. There are elements, though. There are elements that are the same that, if you watch it and watch this one. Yes. For example, in general, each of the characters and like the fact that there's this buffoonish silly boss in their version named David Brent and ours, Michael Scott.
But if you look at the talking heads, there are some differences. Yes. And also like the way the story is told is a little different. I mean, some of the points are the same that happen, but it's told differently. But Greg Daniels was the person who was tasked with Americanizing the British show. Yes. And Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant kind of oversaw that process, but they, for example, they were not on set when we were shooting the pilot. No. No, they came and they visited with us. I remember sitting and getting to have lunch
with Ricky Gervais. Yeah. Oh my gosh, cause I was such a- Were you nervous? Oh yes, I was a super fan of the British version. Me too. And I had been cast in the pilot and they came and they listened to us do a table read.
And afterwards they asked me, John, Rain, Steve, and BJ and Greg to join them for lunch to discuss the show. And I remember thinking, if I get fired tomorrow, at least I got to have lunch with Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant. At least that happened. That was to me just huge. Was it a fun lunch? I was not at that lunch. That was, to me, just huge. Was it a fun lunch?
I was not at that lunch. I was not invited. It was so much fun, Angela. And I remember Ricky saying something in that lunch that was really important. He said, you know, in England, you can be really, really bad at your job for a long time, and you never get fired.
He's like, in America, that's gonna frustrate people. So my one piece of advice is that Michael can be a buffoon. He can be silly, he can be irritating, but you should, I suggest, he said that you show glimpses of him actually being a good salesperson. And we do that throughout the show. You see in future episodes
that he is actually good at sales. And he said that's gonna be an important, I think, piece of the puzzle. in future episodes that he is actually good at sales. And he said, that's gonna be an important, I think, piece of the puzzle. And Stephen Merchant said, my piece of advice would be to lean a little bit more into the Jim and Pam relationship. He said-
He knew the heart of it. He said, that's really gonna be the heart of your show. Cause the British version, they did six episodes for their first season, six episodes for their second season, and one big Christmas special. And they knew that for American television, we were looking to do years.
And we ended up doing 200. So he said, you need to keep the heart beating on the show. And so that's the heart of the show. That's Jim and Pam. OK, I have another fast fact. We filmed the pilot six months before the rest of season one. And we shot it on the second floor of a real office building in Culver City.
So it was an actual office building. And a lot of times on sets, they build the office. So if they want to film and get a certain camera angle, they can move a wall. They can move a window. They can move a door, because they built it. They actually say wall flying out and they move a whole wall. They move a whole wall. It's insane. On our show, because it was in an actual office building, you just had to work with it. And it sort of really lended
itself to the documentary style that all the shots weren't going to look pretty. They weren't going to be lined up just right because they had to work around actual walls and windows. They couldn't just pop them out. I remember speaking to Ken Quapus, our director, about setting certain rules for the documentary style of filming. And he said it was very important to him that for all of the actors and the crew that the set felt like a real working office and a real documentary was happening. And so one of the rules that he came up with was that he cleared the entire set of all
crew members except for a camera operator, a boom operator and himself. Yes. And that was it. That was it. He also made all of the actors come in every morning, go through hair and makeup and then sit at our desks starting at 730 AM and we had to pretend to work. Yes. And he walked around with the documentary crew and filmed us for 30 minutes.
Yeah, just us quietly working. And little shots that you see, for example, of Pam doing whiteout, that is a piece of B-roll from one of those working mornings that we did. And we did that every day on the pilot. Something else about this episode that I noticed is that there is a random exterior shot of a building. Oh, Jenna, let me tell you.
Well, wait, wait, let me grab one of my colorful note cards, as you call them. Exterior shot at 929, nine minutes and 29 seconds. Not our building! With a huge exclamation point. This is a big discovery. This is a big discovery for me. Not only not our building, it wasn't the building
we were filming in. I don't know where they got that shot. I don't know. It's like stock footage from something. I think it was stock footage. And then we never use it again. That was it. That was it.
They should go back and take that out. See you later. And put a shot of the reals under Mifflin exterior. Jenna's getting sassy on you. Yeah, I'm going to call someone. Someone get it right. All right, here is my last fast fact for this episode. and put a shot of the reels under Mifflin exterior. Jenna's getting sassy on you. Yeah, I'm going to call someone. Someone get it right. All right, here is my last fast fact for this episode.
Meredith is not Meredith. She is not. She is Henriette. It's Henriette. Yes, Meredith is played by Henriette Mantell in the pilot episode, not Kate Flannery. Henriette Mantell was a comedy actress who had just broken out because she had played Alice in the Brady Bunch films.
And she was there for the pilot. And then it was six months later that we got picked up and then we started filming the rest of the episodes. And I guess the rumor was she was not available. She was busy. And we had to recast her. So Kate Flannery came in. Here is my fast fact.
Kate Flannery and I met years before the office. We were in a all-female improv group called Bitch Planet. Woohoo! Aw, Bitch Planet. Sunday nights at like 10 p.m. That's when you want to... It's exactly when you want your comedy. That's when you want to watch improv.
Kate and I had known each other for a really long time. And also, Oscar Nunez and I did a sketch comedy show together called Hot Towel. Where do you get these names, Angela? So it was really fun for me because here I am. I was so nervous the first day. I didn't know Oscar had been cast. He didn't know I had been cast.
You guys, this was before smartphones. It's not like you texted someone you got a role or you put it on your social media. There was none of that. So you walked in and were completely surprised. Completely surprised when I saw Oscar. And not only did I see Oscar, but Ken Quapa sat us next to each other.
So I was like, oh my god, I'm going to be OK. That's amazing. My buddy's here. And then Brian walked in as Kevin, and I was like, here we go. We're off to the races. You guys were amazing in accounting. Thank you. My buddy's here. And then Brian walked in as Kevin, and I was like, here we go, we're off to the races. You guys were amazing in accounting. Thank you.
Yeah, it's true. I'm giving you a compliment. Thank you so much. So yeah, so I was so excited to have these friends that I had performed with for years before the office sitting in my little corner back there. I remember meeting everyone for the first time. Do you remember your first impressions of people?
I remember my first impression of Rainn Wilson. Tell me. Well, I met Rainn Wilson at a live test audition. So for all the leads of the show, they brought us into screen test, and they mixed and matched us. There were four Pams and four Dwights and four Jims and four Michaels. And we spent an entire day being mixed and matched with each other. And I remember I met Rainn Wilson, and he was in character, but I couldn't really know that because I didn't know Rainn yet.
And I thought he was the weirdest person I'd ever met in my life. Wait, he was in character the whole time? Yeah. He just was white. Oh, so method, Rainn. He had his hair like that. So method.
But you know what? I kind of did the same thing. I did my same thing. I did my Pam hairstyle. The hairstyle that I wore on the show, I sort of invented through the audition process, that sort of half up, half down scrunchie, air dried curl. And so I was very quiet. I didn't talk to people in the waiting room because I just thought Pam was sort of not
a chatter and I didn't want to get out of character. I remember one of the first things. Wait, this is so random, but it's true. That first week of filming, Rain's wife came to have lunch. And this is the main interaction I remember from Rain during the pilot episode. Okay. Rain introduced me to his wife.
She was pregnant at the time with their son. Yes. And he said, this is my wife Holly, bearer of my seed. And I was like, what? And she started laughing. And, but that was just Rain being Rain. That's Rain.
That is Rain, but Witton Dwight say that. He would also say that. This is Angela, bearer of my seed. Yes, it's amazing how- She's carrying my seed. I'm like, oh my god. I feel like we all have little parts of our characters in us. But I don't know if that's true of you,
because you are so opposite from Angela Martin. I am. I was thinking about how you were saying, you stayed in character and so did Rain. In between your auditions in the lobby, I would not have. I would have been like, chitty chat chat, chitty chat chat. For sure. And then I would have just turned into a bitch when I entered the room.
Well, you know, I didn't have any scenes with Rain in the pilot of Substance. I didn't have any one-on-one scenes. So for me, when we were shooting the pilot, the people that I really bonded with were Steve, John, and you, because you were over the little part. You were my closest seatmate in the office. So you and I bonded.
And I remember after we finished the pilot and we all left and we didn't know if we were gonna be picked up or make any more, shortly after that, I turned 30 years old. It was a big milestone birthday for me. And I really wondered if I should invite any of you guys. And I didn't. I didn invite any of you guys. And I didn't. I didn't invite you guys because I thought,
well, I'm probably never gonna see them again. Should I throw you another 30th birthday party and invite everyone? Would you? And then we could just say happy 30th. Will you? Okay. Cause now you guys are some of my closest friends
and you aren't at my milestone birthday. Okay, we'll have to throw you a 30th birthday party. It won't be weird. All right, guys. So next up, we are going to break down this episode. We're going to really get into the nitty gritty. We're going to talk about scenes and memories and stories, so stick with us. Metrolinx and CrossLinx are reminding everyone to be careful as Eglinton-Crosstown LRT train
testing is in progress. Please be alert as trains can pass at any time on the tracks. Remember to follow all traffic signals. Be careful along our tracks and only make left turns where it's safe to do so. Be alert, be aware, and stay safe. advantage banking account and will give another $100 to a charity of your choice. This great perk and more only at RBC. Visit rbc.com slash get 100 give 100. Conditions apply. Ends January 31st, 2025.
Complete offer eligibility criteria by March 31st, 2025. Choose one of five eligible charities up to $500,000 in total contributions. How can you be sure you're making the right decision when choosing a university? The smart approach is to look at the facts, like the fact that York U graduates have a 90% employer satisfaction rate. That's because across its three GTA campuses, York U's programs are strategically designed
to prepare you for a meaningful career and long-term success. Join us in creating positive change at yorku.ca slash write the future All right, and we're back we're talking about the pilot episode of the office And I think we should talk about some of our favorite moments Jenna. Yes Well, one of my favorite moments is the dynamic between Pam and Michael. I mean selfishly I guess I'm in that moment Yeah, I really loved working with Steve
Carell. I really loved how much he let me be silent and just look at him. And just react. Yes, I loved that. But I especially love whenever Melora Harden, who plays Jan Levinson Gould, got in the mix. She's so commanding. Just like Melora's presence is like, I'm scared of her. Yes. I get it. I get why like, I'm scared of her. Yes. I get it. I get why he was a little scared of her.
And I love the scene where Michael tries to throw Pam under the bus about why he doesn't have the agenda that he's supposed to have. And it's because he told her to throw it in the receptacle, the trash can that is a special filing cabinet for corporate memos. And I remember shooting that scene. And I just remember every time that Pam said,
you told me to put it in a special filing cabinet that is a trash can, that we would giggle. And so I just remember the matter of factness of that moment and how fun that was. Pam totally stood up for herself in her own little way in that moment. Here's the thing about Steve Carell. He is one of the nicest people you will ever meet. He is so nice. I know it's almost even
become like a joke, like Steve Carell is the nicest person ever, but he is. I know. And people ask me a lot, what's it like to work with Steve Carell? Are you just laughing all the time? And no, you're not laughing all the time because Steve isn't on all the time. He's not one of those- He's a real person. He's a real person. And he's, he's, I've worked with comedians who are on all the time. He's not one of those... He's a real person. He's a real person and he's... I've worked with comedians who are on all the time. You walk around and you can just...
They can't turn off their joke-making brain. It drives my car, sorry. It's a little insane. Steve is not like that. You and Steve and I would sit and have long conversations about the best frozen yogurt in the San Fernando Valley. Oh, I will never forget the morning... On Monday mornings, Steve would come out of his office, out of Michael Scott's office between scenes.
He would walk over to Jenna and I, and we would talk about our weekends. And one Monday morning, he walked over, and he was like, ladies, guess what I did this weekend? We're like, what? And he goes, I went to Target. He would talk to us about Target. And he told us about his Target run.
It was really, really sweet. You know, recently, I was in a Michael's, purchasing some supplies for a crafting job, and the checkout guy said, Oh my gosh, now this is getting crazy. This morning, Oscar Nunez came in here, then Steve Carell, and now you? What do you guys all live here?
We love crafting. We love crafting. We love crafting. We're all here. We're all sort of I guess we all live around this one Michael's crafting store. Yeah. I texted Steve and I said, Steve, the checkout guy at Michael's told me you were buying some crafting supplies today. And he said, oh, yes, I needed some glue sticks. He sort of told me what he needed. He's like, what were you there for? But that that is Steve.
That is Steve. That's the kind of stuff we would talk to him about. And so to then, to have that man then shift into this scene where he's just being awful to my character. Awful. Like throwing you under the bus in front of the big boss lady. Yes, when our real dynamic was just like so much love. So in the scene, Jan tells Michael
there's going to be downsizing. Yeah. This is big news. This is important. Michael should be paying attention. We've already established that he's thrown away the agenda for the meeting. Yeah, he should take this seriously.
But instead, he takes a phone call from his friend, Todd Packer. Todd Packer, his party buddy, who he clearly covets. He thinks this guy's amazing. Another interesting fact about this scene is that the voice of Todd Packer that comes on the phone is not the voice of the real Todd Packer. What are you talking about? Dave Keckner ends up playing Todd Packer.
When we meet him in season two, this role is played by Dave Keckner. But Dave was not hired when we shot the pilot. What? He's not? Wait, so I was thinking, it sounds like Dave Keckner. Who is it? But I'm thinking it can't be Dave Keckner, right? All this time I thought it was Dave Keckner.
当我们在第二季见到他时，这个角色由戴夫·凯克纳饰演。但我们拍试播集时，戴夫还没被雇佣。什么？不是他？等等，我在想，听起来像是戴夫·凯克纳啊。那是谁？但我心想不可能是戴夫·凯克纳，对吧？一直以来我都以为是戴夫·凯克纳。
It's not Dave. Who is it? I texted Dave Rogers, our editor, Dave Rogers. Knower of all things. I mean, he is knower of all office facts. He is. Okay, what did Dave say?
不是戴夫。那是谁？我给我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯发了短信。戴夫·罗杰斯，万事通。我是说，他是办公室所有事实的知情者。他确实是。好吧，戴夫怎么说？
Dave said that the voice is played by Toby Huss. Toby Huss. Yes, very famous voice actor. He was on King of the Hill for years. And friends of Greg Daniels. Yes. Toby Huss is so talented. I know.
戴夫说那个声音是托比·哈斯配的。托比·哈斯。是的，非常著名的配音演员。他在《山丘之王》里演了好多年。而且是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的朋友。是的。托比·哈斯太有才了。我知道。
How about that? That is Todd Packer's voice. In the Daniels. Yes. Toby Hus is so talented. I know. How about that? That is Todd Packer's voice. In the pilot episode. Yes. Well, I loved, here's one of the things I loved about the pilot, and just sort of the brilliance that was Ricky Gervais and Stephen Merchant and Greg Daniels and their collaboration building this world out, is that so many truths about the characters were established in all these subtle ways. And one of the things I loved is that Michael is clearly thrilled many like truths about the characters were established in all these subtle ways.
怎么样？那就是托德·帕克的配音。在丹尼尔斯的作品里。是的。托比·哈斯太有才了。我知道。怎么样？那就是托德·帕克的配音。在试播集里。是的。嗯，我喜欢，这是我喜欢试播集的原因之一，还有瑞奇·热维斯、斯蒂芬·莫昌特和格雷格·丹尼尔斯在构建这个世界时的那种才华，他们的合作让关于角色的许多真相以如此微妙的方式建立起来。我喜欢的一点是，迈克尔显然很兴奋，关于角色的许多真相以如此微妙的方式建立起来。
And one of the things I loved is that Michael is clearly thrilled that the camera people are there. Oh, he is so excited. He could not have signed up for this faster. I mean, he jumped at the chance at this. And he thinks he's one of the world's best comedians. Oh, yeah. In the world.
我喜欢的一点是，迈克尔显然很兴奋摄像团队在那里。哦，他太兴奋了。他报名参加这个节目简直不能再快了。我是说，他抓住了这个机会。而且他认为自己是世界上最优秀的喜剧演员之一。哦，是的。在世界上。
He has had the funniest people in the world. He has that amazing talking head where he talks about who his heroes are. Yes. And they are Bob Hope, Abraham Lincoln. Bono. And God, probably. He said probably. Probably God.
他拥有世界上最有趣的人。他有一个很棒的访谈片段，他在那里谈论谁是他的英雄。是的。他们是鲍勃·霍普、亚伯拉罕·林肯。波诺。还有上帝，可能吧。他说可能。可能是上帝。
And here's a little tidbit. Steve wrote that. He did? Yes. Oh my God, I love that. I didn't know that. Yeah, Greg asked him, would you mind writing a list of who you believe are Michael Scott's heroes?
这里有个小花絮。史蒂夫写的。他写的？是的。天哪，我喜欢这个。我不知道。是的，格雷格问他，你介意写一份你认为迈克尔·斯科特的英雄名单吗？
Oh, so brilliant. And it made it in. Yes. Well, and he just, every chance he gets, he's like looking to the camera and doing his comedy bits. And this sort of sets up just Michael's love of being liked and being appreciated. And he wants everyone to think he's like the fun boss.
哦，太天才了。而且它被用上了。是的。嗯，他只要有机会，就会看向镜头表演他的喜剧桥段。这确立了迈克尔对被喜欢和被赏识的渴望。他希望每个人都认为他是那种有趣的经理。
And he thinks he's legitimately talented. Well there's that scene where he does the six million dollar man where he's walking away from Pam's desk. I could not get through that scene and in fact, in order to get my reaction shot, they had to make Steve leave the set because I couldn't get through it. So that reaction of me was not while Steve was actually doing anything because every time he did it, I lost it.
而且他认为自己确实很有才华。嗯，有那个他模仿《无敌金刚》的场景，他从帕姆的桌子旁走开。我无法演完那个场景，事实上，为了拍到我的反应镜头，他们不得不让史蒂夫离开片场，因为我演不下去。所以那个我的反应镜头并不是史蒂夫在表演时拍的，因为每次他做那个动作，我就忍不住笑场。
You started laughing. Well, he's so giddy to do his $6 million man. I timed it because as I watched it, I was like, wow, this is a long time to commit to this bit because he's like, fadadadadadadada, fadadadadadada. He did it. It started at nine minutes, 40 seconds, and it doesn't end until 10 minutes, two seconds. Oh my gosh.
你开始笑了。嗯，他做他的《无敌金刚》动作时太兴奋了。我计时了，因为我看的时候心想，哇，投入这个桥段的时间太长了，因为他一直在“哒哒哒哒哒哒哒”。他做到了。从9分40秒开始，一直到10分2秒才结束。天哪。
That is 22 seconds of the slow-mo bit. I think that's why. That's a ton. When you think of the whole scope of an episode for 22 seconds, he went... I mean, that's probably why I couldn't get through it. That's why they couldn't get a reaction of me, because I couldn't get a reaction of me because I couldn't hold it for 20 seconds. I couldn't hold a straight face that long. And he was so desperate for you to look at him and have some kind of reaction.
那是22秒的慢动作桥段。我想这就是原因。太长了。当你想到一整集的时间跨度，他用了22秒……我是说，这可能就是我演不下去的原因。这就是为什么他们拍不到我的反应，因为我无法坚持20秒。我无法保持那么久的严肃表情。而且他非常渴望你看着他并做出某种反应。
Oh man. Okay. What else? What else? There's the conference room scene where Michael officially announces that there is going to be downsizing at Dunder Mifflin. This is a big theme of the pilot. This is the news that Jan gives him
天哪。好吧。还有什么？还有什么？有那个会议室场景，迈克尔正式宣布邓德·米夫林公司要裁员。这是试播集的一个大主题。这是简告诉他的消息。
when she comes into the office, that Dunder Mifflin can no longer support both a Scranton branch and a Stanford branch, and that they're gonna have to prove who is the branch that should stay. But even if Scranton gets to stay, there might be downsizing of employees. Yeah, the company's hurting, and they have to make make some cutbacks and they have to fire some people.
当她走进办公室时，她说邓德·米夫林无法同时支持斯克兰顿分部和斯坦福分部，他们必须证明哪个分部应该留下来。但即使斯克兰顿留下来，也可能会有员工裁减。是的，公司经营困难，他们必须削减开支，必须解雇一些人。
Yes. And so Michael goes into the conference room and this is the first time we see Michael in the conference room. And of course Dwight won't give him the space to do that. It's their first power struggle, which you'll see for years to come. It's the first time he refers to himself as the assistant regional manager, which is great. And I noticed something about this conference room scene. What? I bet I have it on my note card. I bet you have it that there are some extras in this scene that are never to be seen again.
是的。于是迈克尔走进会议室，这是我们第一次看到迈克尔在会议室。当然，德怀特不会给他空间做这件事。这是他们的第一次权力斗争，你会在未来几年里一直看到。这是他第一次称自己为助理区域经理，这太棒了。我注意到这个会议室场景的一些事情。什么？我打赌我的笔记卡上有。我打赌你写了，这个场景里有一些群众演员再也不会出现了。
There are two women. Do you want me to refer to it? Let me just tell you what I wrote on my note card. Conference room faces, semicolon. So in the background, there are two women and they are the real production company accountants for our show. Yes, we needed more people to fill out the space
有两个女人。你想让我提一下吗？让我告诉你我在笔记卡上写了什么。会议室面孔，分号。背景里有两个女人，她们是我们剧组真正的会计。是的，我们需要更多人来填补空间。
and they pulled in our actual accountants from our production office. Yes, Ken Guapas, the director, walked into the production office and asked if anyone would like to be in the background of a scene. And those two women came and sat there for that couple of hours. They were so giddy.
他们把我们制作办公室真正的会计拉了过来。是的，导演肯·夸皮斯走进制作办公室，问有没有人想在场景背景里露个脸。那两个女人就过来坐了那几个小时。她们太兴奋了。
They loved it. They loved it. They loved it. And then also in the conference room, some faces you might see sprinkled through the first season, but then they don't go past that season, are Lou Ann Kelly, who worked in the annex.
她们喜欢极了。她们喜欢极了。她们喜欢极了。还有在会议室里，有些面孔你可能会在第一季里零星看到，但之后就不会再出现了，比如在附楼工作的卢安·凯利。
She is someone that you see a lot. I get asked a lot, who is the lady in the annex? Yes, she was sort of over where Mindy ends up sitting by Kelly's desk. And then also, of course, Devin and Creed, who ultimately do have a storyline that will come later. But not until season two. That's right.
她是那种你经常看到的人。我经常被问到，附楼里的那个女士是谁？是的，她大概坐在明迪最终坐的凯利桌子旁边。还有，当然，德文和克里德，他们最终确实有一个会在后面出现的故事情节。但要到第二季才会有。没错。
So for an entire season, you just see Devin and Creed in the background of scenes. They don't get any lines until the second season. But that is the only scene our actual accountants are in, because then they had to go back to work. They did. They had to actually go back to being accountants for the show. I think this is an interesting tidbit.
所以整整一季，你只能在场景背景里看到德文和克里德。直到第二季他们才有台词。但那是我们真正的会计出现的唯一场景，因为之后她们必须回去工作。她们确实回去了。她们必须回去做剧组的会计。我觉得这是一个有趣的花絮。
Phyllis Smith, who plays Phyllis on the show, she was the casting associate for The Office. So when I auditioned for The Office, she read my audition scenes with me. Everyone. I read my scene with Phyllis. That's who I read my scene with. Yes. And Ken Quapus, the director, was so taken with how she did her readings with the actors.
菲利斯·史密斯，在剧中饰演菲利斯，她是《办公室》的选角助理。所以当我为《办公室》试镜时，她和我一起读了我的试镜剧本。每个人。我和菲利斯一起读了我的剧本。那就是和我一起读剧本的人。是的。导演肯·夸皮斯对她与演员对戏的方式印象深刻。
She's so earnest, you guys. She is so earnest. And so real that he said to Greg Daniels, I want her on the show. Can I give her a part on the show? And so Phyllis went from being a casting associate, which she He said to Greg Daniels, I want her on the show. Can I give her a part on the show? And so Phyllis went from being a casting associate, which she had done for years with Alison Jones,
她太真诚了，伙计们。她太真诚了。而且太真实了，以至于他对格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，我想让她参演。我能给她一个角色吗？于是菲利斯从选角助理变成了……他对格雷格·丹尼尔斯说，我想让她参演。我能给她一个角色吗？于是菲利斯从选角助理变成了，她和艾莉森·琼斯一起做了多年，
the casting director, worked with Phyllis, to having a part on this pilot. And I think because we all thought the show was going nowhere, it was fine. And after the pilot was over, she went back to being a casting associate. She went right back to work. Phyllis has a great story that she tells that the way she found out that she got Phyllis is that she got sides and they said Phyllis.
选角导演，和菲利斯一起工作，到在这个试播集里有了角色。我想因为我们都以为这部剧没戏了，所以没关系。试播集结束后，她又回去做选角助理了。她直接回去工作了。菲利斯有一个很棒的故事，她说她发现自己得到菲利斯这个角色是因为她拿到了剧本，上面写着菲利斯。
Oh, so there was a character and they named it Phyllis. And Kim was like, that's you, you're Phyllis. And she was like, what? We wrote a part for you based on the numerous readings with actors. You're now in the show, Phyllis. Which is just so cool, because Phyllis had wanted to be an actress. She had been an actress. She had been a burlesque dancer.
哦，所以有一个角色，他们命名为菲利斯。肯说，那就是你，你是菲利斯。她说，什么？我们根据你和演员的多次对戏为你写了一个角色。你现在在剧里了，菲利斯。这太酷了，因为菲利斯一直想当演员。她曾经是演员。她曾经是滑稽歌舞剧演员。
Burlesque dancer? No one can shimmy. No one can shimmy like Phyllis. She has a great shimmy. She had an amazing photo on her desk, because Ken Quapus wanted us to personalize our desk for the pilot episode and moving forward. So we all brought in something from home. I have a photo of myself and my
滑稽歌舞剧演员？没人能像菲利斯那样扭动。她扭得太棒了。她桌上有一张很棒的照片，因为肯·夸皮斯想让我们为试播集及以后的拍摄个性化我们的办公桌。所以我们都从家里带了东西。我有一张我和我
grandmother and a frame that says, I heart grandma. And my eyes are closed in the photo, but my grandmother framed it anyway. And so I have that on my desk and it just kind of like tickled me and made me think of my grandmother. I had a picture of me and my sister swimming in Lake of the Ozarks. Yes, and Phyllis had a picture of herself in her full burlesque outfit with a red feather boa draped over her shoulders.
祖母的照片，相框上写着“我爱祖母”。照片里我闭着眼睛，但我祖母还是把它装裱起来了。所以我把它放在桌上，这让我觉得很有趣，让我想起了我的祖母。我有一张我和我姐姐在欧扎克湖游泳的照片。是的，菲利斯有一张她穿着全套滑稽歌舞剧服装的照片，肩上披着红色的羽毛围巾。
Angela, let's take a quick break. Okay, Jenna. You gonna get a snack? Why? Because you always get a snack during the breaks. I do. There are two sides to McDonald's new Cajun Ranch McRisbee. On the one hand, it's a masterpiece centered around that crispy, juicy, tender seasoned chicken.
安吉拉，我们休息一下吧。好的，珍娜。你要去吃零食吗？为什么？因为你休息时总是吃零食。我确实吃。麦当劳新的卡真牧场风味麦乐鸡有两个方面。一方面，它是以那种酥脆、多汁、鲜嫩的调味鸡肉为核心的杰作。
On the other hand, McRisbee fans are going to love the bold, tangy taste of the new Cajun Ranch flavors. In other words, the Cajun Ranch McRisbee is a work of art for all your senses. Yep, like a flavorful fusion. Precisely. When is the gallery opening? It already has. Experience the Cajun Ranch McRisbee today for a limited time only at Participating McDonald's in Canada. So then we get to that crazy scene where Michael is walking Ryan the temp around. So he's just been told that we need downsizing. And then he hires a temp. It's the exact opposite of downsizing.
另一方面，麦乐鸡粉丝会喜欢新的卡真牧场风味那种大胆、浓郁的味道。换句话说，卡真牧场麦乐鸡是为你所有感官准备的艺术品。是的，就像一种风味融合。正是如此。画廊什么时候开幕？已经开了。今天就去加拿大参与活动的麦当劳体验卡真牧场麦乐鸡吧。然后我们到了那个疯狂的场景，迈克尔带着临时工瑞恩到处走。他刚被告知需要裁员。然后他雇了一个临时工。这和裁员完全相反。
It's the opposite. Can I just say one thing I love too is when Dwight has his talking head and he said, I've been talking about downsizing for years. I brought it up in my interview. Like, who does that? He was like interviewing for a job and it's like, you should downsize. I would like this job.
这是相反的。我能说一件我也喜欢的事吗，就是德怀特做访谈时说，我多年来一直谈论裁员。我在面试时就提到了。谁会那样做？他面试一份工作时说，你应该裁员。我想要这份工作。
I suggest you get rid of three other people. So here's a little fun fact. It's not a fast fact, but a fun fact is that BJ Novak was the first person cast on the show. He was? He was. Greg Daniels saw him doing standup comedy and he thought he was like, this guy.
我建议你裁掉其他三个人。这里有个有趣的小事实。这不是快讯，而是趣闻，那就是BJ·诺瓦克是第一个被选中的演员。是他？是的。格雷格·丹尼尔斯看他表演单口喜剧，他心想，就是这家伙。
I want this guy. And so he offered BJ a role as both a writer and the role of Ryan the temp on the show. So when I came in for my audition, BJ was already cast. He was the very first person. And he was also the first example of that synergy of having people who were both performers and writers for the show. Which was so great. Something that we haven't talked about, but we will talk about it many times as the show goes, is that what a wonderful creative collaboration we had between the
我想要这家伙。于是他给了BJ一个角色，既是编剧，又是剧中的临时工瑞恩。所以当我来试镜时，BJ已经被选中了。他是第一个。他也是那种既是表演者又是编剧的协同效应的第一个例子。这太棒了。我们还没谈过的一件事，但随着剧集的进行我们会谈很多次，那就是我们在
writers and the actors. And that was because of Greg Daniels. He sort of set the tone that he wanted this creative collaboration. He wanted to hear our ideas and he wanted writers on the set. And I think we were just so much the better for it. I've been on other shows now that where the writers and actors are separate and there's not a lot of collaboration. It feels weird after having experienced something else. No, Greg really trusted us to be the experts of our characters. So whenever he was trying to mull something over
编剧和演员之间有着多么美妙的创意合作。这多亏了格雷格·丹尼尔斯。他定下了基调，他想要这种创意合作。他想听我们的想法，他想让编剧在片场。我觉得我们因此受益匪浅。我现在参加过其他剧组，那里的编剧和演员是分开的，没有太多合作。在经历过那种合作后，这感觉很奇怪。不，格雷格真的很信任我们，让我们成为自己角色的专家。所以每当他试图思考某件事
or justify something, he would come to us and ask us, just in the way that he went to Steve and said, hey, do you have any thoughts on who Michael Scott's heroes would be? He trusted us to have done our homework and know our characters so well that we could contribute. Yeah, it was great. It was really special.
或证明某件事时，他会来问我们，就像他去找史蒂夫说，嘿，你对迈克尔·斯科特的英雄是谁有什么想法吗？他信任我们已经做了功课，非常了解我们的角色，以至于我们可以做出贡献。是的，这太棒了。这真的很特别。
So also in that scene, that is the famous stapler in Jell-O. Yaw. The stapler goes in Jell-O. I have seen so many people recreate this. How? How? I am blown away. Every time I see a fan tag me in a photo
在这个场景里，还有那个著名的订书机放进果冻里。是的。订书机进了果冻。我见过很多人重现这个。怎么做到的？怎么做到的？我惊呆了。每次我看到粉丝在照片里标记我，
where they put something in Jell-O, I'm like, where to go? I know. Something we haven't mentioned is the flirtation between Jim and Pam in this episode. And it goes on through the whole first two thirds of this episode or three quarters of this episode. Little things. What did I write on my pink note card, Jenna?
他们把东西放进果冻里，我就想，怎么做到的？我知道。我们还没提到的一件事是吉姆和帕姆在这一集里的调情。这贯穿了这一集的三分之二或四分之三。小细节。我在粉色笔记卡上写了什么，珍娜？
Mixed berries. End quotes. He's on to me. Yeah. That is one of the cutest things. It is so pure. It is. Like that's flirting for them. That he knows your favorite yogurt.
混合浆果。引号结束。他发现我了。是的。这是最可爱的事情之一。它太纯粹了。确实。对他们来说这就是调情。他知道你最喜欢的酸奶。
But up until the end, you are just sort of following this flirtation between the two characters and then all of a sudden Roy walks in the door. Roy, David Dinman. Carrying that weird trash bag. We never know what's in that trash bag. What is he carrying? I loved it so much when John is Jim is like, what's in the bag? And Roy's like, yeah, just tell her. Yeah, tell her I'll meet her in the car.
但在最后之前，你只是在跟随这两个角色之间的调情，然后突然罗伊走进了门。罗伊，大卫·丁曼。提着那个奇怪的垃圾袋。我们永远不知道那个垃圾袋里装的是什么。他提着什么？我太喜欢约翰饰演的吉姆问“袋子里是什么”的时候了。罗伊说，是的，告诉她。是的，告诉她我在车里等她。
Yeah. But I think it is such a, I remember watching the pilot with people and having them be shocked. Yeah. By like, oh, wait. Oh, crap. She's been engaged three years? Three years.
是的。但我认为这真是……我记得和人们一起看试播集，看到他们感到震惊。是的。比如，哦，等等。哦，糟糕。她订婚三年了？三年。
Holy moly. Yeah. And then Jim has that heartbreaking talking head. Do I think I'll be invited to the wedding? Oh, Jim. Breaking hearts. John Krasinski breaking hearts. He's breaking hearts right out of the gate.
天哪。然后吉姆有了那个令人心碎的访谈。我会被邀请参加婚礼吗？哦，吉姆。心碎了。约翰·卡拉辛斯基让人心碎。他一出场就在让人心碎。
He's breaking hearts. He really is. So another really cute flirty moment between Jim and Pam. After the conference room scene, where we all find out there's gonna be downsizing, the camera cuts to different groups of people talking about downsizing. But when it cuts to Jim and Pam,
他让人心碎。他确实是。所以吉姆和帕姆之间另一个非常可爱的调情时刻。在会议室场景之后，我们都知道要裁员了，镜头切到不同的小组讨论裁员。但当切到吉姆和帕姆时，
we are not talking about downsizing. What are you guys talking about? We are talking about your cat party. Oh! Do you remember this? I do, I do. So this is, I feel like this is really significant and kind of goes on the heels of what we were talking about
我们没有在谈论裁员。你们在谈论什么？我们在谈论你的猫咪派对。哦！你记得这个吗？我记得，我记得。所以我觉得这非常有意义，而且延续了我们刚才谈论的
with Greg wanting to collaborate with actors. So Ken said, listen, I'm just going to roll the camera. You two just talk to each other. Don't push it. Just talk. Make each other laugh. And so here's something you should know is that earlier in the scene, Ken had asked me if I would pass out papers in the background. Yeah. I only had three lines in the episode. Otherwise, I was just background, basically, for that pilot. So he asked me if I would pass out papers. And I had just doodled a little drawing of a cat.
关于格雷格想与演员合作的话题。肯说，听着，我只是要开机拍摄。你们两个就互相聊聊。别刻意。就聊聊。让对方笑。所以这里有一件事你应该知道，在场景早些时候，肯问我是否可以在背景里分发文件。是的。我在这一集里只有三句台词。否则，我基本上只是那个试播集的背景板。所以他问我是否可以分发文件。我刚随手画了一只猫。
And I said, you're invited to Sprinkle's birthday party. I just sort of made up that my character had found a cat in the parking lot. I was just sort of bored. We all made up backstories for ourselves. I just made up backstory that my character had found this cat in the parking lot. I don't know, I was just sort of bored and... We all made up backstories for ourselves. Yeah, I just made up backstory that my character had found this cat in the parking lot. But I think it's really significant because you, in your character,
我说，你被邀请参加斯普林克尔的生日派对。我只是编造说我的角色在停车场发现了一只猫。我当时只是有点无聊。我们都为自己编造了背景故事。我只是编造了一个背景故事，说我的角色在停车场发现了这只猫。我不知道，我只是有点无聊……我们都为自己编造了背景故事。是的，我只是编造了一个背景故事，说我的角色在停车场发现了这只猫。但我认为这非常有意义，因为你，在你的角色
actory prep work, decided that your character was a crazy cat lady. I guess I did. Because you kind of decorated your desk with some cat stuff. Now, the prop department that set my desk had a paperclip holder that was a cat laying on its side, and it holds paper clips.
准备工作中，决定你的角色是一个疯狂的爱猫女士。我想我是。因为你用一些猫的东西装饰了你的办公桌。现在，布置我桌子的道具部门有一个订书机架，是一只猫侧躺着，用来放订书针。
OK. I took it from my desk. I still have it. I might have stolen it as a memento. And so I think I was just looking at that, and I was doodling. And truth be told, there's only about three things I can draw in real life that look like the actual thing.
好的。我把它从桌子上拿走了。我还有它。我可能把它当作纪念品偷走了。所以我认为我当时只是看着它，然后我在涂鸦。说实话，现实生活中我只能画出大约三样看起来像实物的东西。
And one of them is a cat? One of them is a cat. That's kind of true for me. I can draw a palm And one of them is a cat. One of them is a cat. That's kind of true for me. I can draw a palm tree. I can draw a cat. And I can draw Snoopy. Hey. There you go.
其中一个是猫？其中一个是猫。这对我来说是真的。我可以画一棵棕榈树。我可以画一只猫。我还可以画史努比。嘿。你看。
And I guess I had just doodled a cat. And so I'd written on it. So maybe my poor skills at drawing is also what gave birth to this moment. But I drew this cat. And I wrote, you're invited to Sprinkles birthday party in the parking lot. And you gave it to me.
我想我当时只是画了一只猫。我在上面写了字。所以也许我糟糕的绘画技巧也促成了这一刻。但我画了这只猫。我写道，你被邀请参加斯普林克尔在停车场的生日派对。你把它给了我。
I handed it to you earlier. I remember, and it was weird. I remember getting it in the background of the scene and thinking, I don't know what this is. But I stuck it to my computer monitor. Yeah, it was on a Post-It and you stuck it to your computer. So when Ken Coop has asked me to talk to John
我早些时候递给了你。我记得，这很奇怪。我记得在场景背景里收到它时心想，我不知道这是什么。但我把它贴在了我的电脑显示器上。是的，它在便利贴上，你把它贴在了电脑上。所以当肯·夸皮斯让我和约翰聊聊
about anything, to do the scene, just talk to each other, I noticed that post-it note and I said, are you gonna go something like, I can't remember if it's cat party on Sunday. And he... He's like, oh no, it's ridiculous. No, definitely not. And then we giggle.
任何事情，来演这个场景，只是互相聊天，我注意到了那张便利贴，我说，你要去……类似，我不记得是不是周日的猫咪派对。然后他……他说，哦不，这太荒谬了。不，绝对不去。然后我们咯咯笑。
And that is the bit that they left in the episode. And that's the birth of Sprinkles. That was the birth of Sprinkles. That turned into this cat birthday party. Greg honed in on that. He was like, what is the cat birthday party? And I said, well, Angela gave me this post-it note about her birthday party for her cat or something.
这就是他们留在剧集里的桥段。那是斯普林克尔的诞生。那是斯普林克尔的诞生。这变成了猫咪生日派对。格雷格抓住了这一点。他问，猫咪生日派对是什么？我说，嗯，安吉拉给了我这张关于她猫生日派对的便利贴。
And he loved it. And then for four seasons, we discussed Sprinkles until his untimely death in the freezer. Yes, but that's another episode. I won't make you think about it. Because it's one of my favorite Michael moments, too. Yeah, so that was really fun, how just these little elements of us in the background sort of being bored and improvising
他很喜欢。然后有四季的时间，我们都在讨论斯普林克尔，直到它在冷冻室里不幸去世。是的，但那是另一集了。我不会让你去想它的。因为这也是我最喜欢的迈克尔时刻之一。是的，所以这真的很有趣，我们这些在背景里无聊并即兴发挥的小元素
made it into the show. Yeah. It's so special to me. All right, so I have something that I am so curious about. And Jenna, I don't even know if you know this. Fans out there, I don't know if you know it or if we need to text Dave Rogers, our editor extraordinaire. So my Dwayne Angela fans, did you
竟然进了剧集。是的。这对我来说太特别了。好吧，我有一件事非常好奇。珍娜，我甚至不知道你知不知道。粉丝们，我不知道你们知不知道，或者我们是否需要给我们的剪辑师戴夫·罗杰斯发短信。所以我的德怀特和安吉拉粉丝们，你们
notice in the pilot episode that Dwight is singing Little Drummer Boy as he unpacks his desk? Angela. He's singing like, come, they told me, pa rum pum pum pum. But then he goes, do do do, do, do, do, do, do, do. And then in season three, I karaoke, little drummer boy, and Dwight joins in and sings with me. Now that story is that I was very nervous to sing.
注意到在试播集里，德怀特在整理办公桌时在唱《小鼓手男孩》吗？安吉拉。他在唱，来吧，他们告诉我，哒哒哒哒哒。但他唱的是，嘟嘟嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟，嘟。然后在第三季，我唱《小鼓手男孩》卡拉OK，德怀特加入并和我一起唱。那个故事是，我唱歌非常紧张。
I don't like singing in front of people. And, and Rain, as Dwight just jumped in and kind of like supported me, so I wasn't up there alone. And he kneeled down and he held the microphone for me. And I'm just like, oh my God. I mean, what? That's crazy. I feel like that has to be a coincidence.
我不喜欢在别人面前唱歌。而且，雷恩饰演的德怀特只是跳了进来，支持我，所以我不是一个人站在那里。他跪下来，为我拿着麦克风。我心想，天哪。我是说，什么？这太疯狂了。我觉得这一定是巧合。
I think it's a coincidence, but how, and so many fans say to me, like what amazing synergy it is that Dwight is singing Little Drummer Boy in the pilot, and then in season three, I sing it to him. Now, did a writer remember that? Was that something that, like, was, or was that just in the subconscious of the show?
我认为这是巧合，但怎么会……这么多粉丝对我说，德怀特在试播集里唱《小鼓手男孩》，然后在第三季我唱给他听，这种协同效应太棒了。编剧记得吗？那是某件事，还是只是剧集的潜意识？
I don't know. I don't know. You know what I found? I found this article. And I can't remember where. I apologize. I found an article that was all about secret messages in the pilot episode. And one of the secret messages that someone points out
我不知道。我不知道。你知道我发现了什么吗？我发现了这篇文章。我不记得在哪里了。我很抱歉。我发现了一篇关于试播集里秘密信息的文章。有人指出的秘密信息之一
is that in the scene where Roy comes in the door for the first time, the boom mic dips into frame. And someone wondered, was that a nod to the boom operator Brian that we will meet in season nine? No, that was just an accident. Was it foreshadowing to let us know that there are three men in Pam's life, Jim, Roy, and Brian? No, no, that was just a boom operator accident,
是当罗伊第一次走进门时，吊杆麦克风伸进了画面。有人想，那是对我们在第九季会遇到的吊杆操作员布莱恩的致敬吗？不，那只是个意外。那是为了让我们知道帕姆生命中有三个男人：吉姆、罗伊和布莱恩吗？不，不，那只是吊杆操作员的失误，
and they left it in because it's a documentary. Yes, we left that stuff in all the time. That was the thing that we coveted that. We loved it. If the camera person fumbled or if the boom accidentally wasn't shot, we still used it. And we could. And that was actually great.
他们把它留下了，因为这是纪录片。是的，我们一直保留那些东西。那是我们梦寐以求的。我们喜欢它。如果摄像师笨手笨脚，或者吊杆意外没拍好，我们还是用了它。而且我们可以用。这实际上很棒。
Because sometimes you're on a set, and your best take is ruined because of some technical accident on the set, but we were able to use all of it. We didn't have to put it on the cutting room floor. Okay, so yeah, so no conspiracy, but yeah, I don't know if Dwight singing Little Drummer Boy in the pilot and Angela singing it
因为有时你在片场，最好的镜头因为某种技术失误被毁了，但我们能够使用所有这些镜头。我们不必把它们扔进剪辑室的垃圾桶。好吧，所以没有阴谋，但我不知道德怀特在试播集里唱《小鼓手男孩》和安吉拉在第三季的圣诞派对上唱它
in Benny Hauna Christmas in season three is just a crazy coincidence, but it's cool, right? It's a pretty cool observation. I actually really love these fan theories because I like to think that these accidents or coincidences, if they are accidents, are part of a fun collective unconscious thing that kind of lend itself to the magic of the show. Wow, Jenna, that was really deep. It kind of was.
是不是只是一个疯狂的巧合，但这很酷，对吧？这是一个非常酷的观察。我实际上非常喜欢这些粉丝理论，因为我喜欢认为这些意外或巧合，如果它们是意外的话，是某种有趣的集体潜意识的一部分，这增加了剧集的魔力。哇，珍娜，这太深刻了。确实有点。
I got real philosophical there. Oh my gosh, I feel like I just had like a vision of what you were like in college or something. Yeah. Like you sat around like maybe like you wore like black turtlenecks and like I don't know. I was kind of like I was kind of like Art Show Pam. Art Show Pam! With my turtleneck.
我变得很哲学。天哪，我觉得我刚才看到了你在大学时的样子。是的。就像你坐在那里，可能穿着黑色高领毛衣，我不知道。我当时有点像“艺术展帕姆”。艺术展帕姆！穿着我的高领毛衣。
Yeah. My jumper. Well, I like it. Spilling philosophy. All right, Angela, what have you got for us? I only had one speaking scene in the pilot and so did Brian. It was back in accounting when Angela and Kevin are trying to figure out who's going to be fired for downsizing. We were really nervous about shooting the scene. It's the only time we speak. And it was at the end
是的。我的毛衣。嗯，我喜欢。散发哲学气息。好吧，安吉拉，你有什么要说的？我在试播集里只有一个说话的场景，布莱恩也是。那是在会计部，安吉拉和凯文试图弄清楚谁会被裁员。我们对拍摄那个场景非常紧张。这是我们唯一一次说话。是在一天结束的时候，
of the day, Ken Quapus, who's, you know, we've said the nicest guy was like, go ahead. And I said, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And Brian, as Kevin says, yeah, it'll probably be you. And Ken came up to me and goes, hey, Angela, can you do it again? And I'm like, just give it like half. Give it half. Hmm.
肯·夸皮斯，你知道，我们说过他是最好的人，他说，开始吧。我说，有人会被解雇。那可能是我。布莱恩饰演的凯文说，是的，那可能就是你。肯走过来对我说，嘿，安吉拉，你能再来一次吗？我说，就减半吧。减半。嗯。
So I guess I was like, was I too big? Was I like, somebody's going to be fired. It'll probably be me. And then so I was like, somebody will probably be fired. It'll probably be me. Someone's going to get fired. Is that the exact line? Somebody's going will probably be fired it'll probably be me someone's gonna get fired is that the exact line somebody's gonna be fired it'll probably be me then he came up and he goes half of that I said oh okay so then I was like somebody's gonna be fired it'll probably be me and he goes half of that oh my I said oh my god I'm gonna get fired because I'm
所以我猜我当时是……我演得太夸张了吗？我是说，有人会被解雇。那可能是我。然后我说，有人可能会被解雇。那可能是我。有人会被解雇。那是确切的台词吗？有人会被解雇，那可能是我，有人会被解雇，那是确切的台词吗？有人会被解雇，那可能是我，然后他走过来，他说减半。我说，哦，好吧，然后我说，有人会被解雇，那可能是我，他说减半。哦，天哪，我说，天哪，我要被解雇了，因为我
like an improv sketch comedy actor and clearly I'm too broad. And so ultimately the take they use, by the end of it, I literally was like, somebody's gonna be fired, it'll probably be me. And then Brian's like, yeah, it'll probably be you. And Ken was like, we got it. I was like. Do you wanna point out what you noticed
像个即兴小品演员，显然我演得太夸张了。所以最终他们用的那个镜头，到最后，我真的说，有人会被解雇，那可能是我。然后布莱恩说，是的，那可能就是你。肯说，我们拍到了。我说。你想指出你注意到的
about this scene as well about Kevin? Here's my tidbit guys, is that when I watch this and Brian, I want to call you about it. You just sound like Brian to me. You don't sound like the Kevin voice. Okay, can we play it? I bet it's going to be me, probably. It's going to be me.
关于这个场景，关于凯文的事情吗？这是我的花絮，伙计们，当我看到这个时，布莱恩，我想给你打电话。你听起来就像布莱恩。你听起来不像凯文的声音。好吧，我们可以放一下吗？我打赌那会是我，可能吧。那会是我。
Yeah, it'll be you. That's Brian! Oh my gosh! That's Brian! That is Brian's voice. That's not, cause Kevin would have been like, yeah, it'll probably be me. It'll probably be me. Yeah. That's a horrible because Kevin would have been like, yeah, it'll probably be me.
是的，那会是你。那是布莱恩！天哪！那是布莱恩！那是布莱恩的声音。那不是，因为凯文会说，是的，那可能是我。那可能是我。是的。那太糟糕了，因为凯文会说，是的，那可能是我。
Yeah. That's a horrible Kevin. We just really did not do that well. Oh my gosh. I want to call Brian about it. But when I watched it, I was like, wait a second. Like that's Brian. But I think in the pilot, we were still sort of like figuring out our characters and who they were. However, I have to say, Angela. What? I went into the deleted scenes on the DVD,
是的。那是个糟糕的凯文。我们真的演得不好。天哪。我想给布莱恩打电话。但当我看到它时，我心想，等一下。那是布莱恩。但我认为在试播集里，我们还在摸索我们的角色以及他们是谁。然而，我必须说，安吉拉。什么？我看了DVD里的删除片段，
season one DVD, and there is, this is something we did on the pilot. Some of it was an acting exercise where they called us each into the conference room separately and they just asked us unscripted lines about our characters and about our relationship to other characters. I remember this.
第一季DVD，有这个，这是我们在试播集里做的事情。有些是表演练习，他们把我们分别叫进会议室，问我们关于角色和我们与其他角色关系的即兴台词。我记得这个。
It wasn't written. It was not written. We just improvised. Oh, so this was sort of, I think, an exercise that Ken wanted to do that Greg and Ken came up with. In addition to that thing where they filmed us all just working, they also filmed us being interviewed in character. And I think Greg thought, this will be great.
这不是写好的。不是写好的。我们只是即兴发挥。哦，所以这大概是肯想做的一个练习，格雷格和肯想出来的。除了他们拍摄我们工作的那件事，他们还拍摄了我们以角色身份接受采访。我想格雷格心想，这会很棒。
Maybe I could use some of these little tidbits here and there. Well, there is a series of interviews with each of the members of accounting. Oh my god. Where you guys are all trash talking each other very subtly. And Angela, you have this incredible deleted scene talking head where they ask you about Oscar.
也许我可以用这些小花絮。嗯，有一系列对会计部每个成员的采访。天哪。你们都在非常微妙地互相说坏话。安吉拉，你有一个令人难以置信的删除片段访谈，他们问你关于奥斯卡的事。
Is this where I compare him to a stapler? Yes. Sam, can you pull that up so we can listen to that? Oscar, how do I describe him? He's like a stapler. Do I need a stapler? Yes. But I'm still the one that has to push it down.
这是我把他比作订书机的地方吗？是的。萨姆，你能调出来让我们听听吗？奥斯卡，我怎么形容他？他就像一个订书机。我需要订书机吗？是的。但我还是那个必须把它按下去的人。
I did. I improvised that because I was trying to think of, like, what? Like, how does Angela see Oscar and he's just like he's necessary but he's a he ends up being more work for her. Yes. He's annoying. What was so clear to me when I was watching them was this accounting dynamic had already started. Yeah. This little pod that you guys formed, this little trio. It was there from the very beginning. Also, I do have to point fans, all of the deleted scenes are fantastic.
我确实说了。我即兴发挥了，因为我在想，像什么？安吉拉怎么看奥斯卡，他只是……他是必要的，但他最终给她增加了更多工作。是的。他很烦人。当我看着他们时，对我来说非常清楚的是，这种会计动态已经开始了。是的。你们组成的小团体，这个小三人组。从一开始就在那里。另外，我必须指出，粉丝们，所有的删除片段都很棒。
Rainn Wilson has some talking heads. There is a long extended deleted scene talking head of him talking to Ken Quapus, who played the documentarian for us. He would ask us the questions, our director, all about where the boom microphone was. Rain as Dwight was very distracted by the boom.
雷恩·威尔逊有一些访谈。有一个很长的扩展删除片段访谈，他与肯·夸皮斯交谈，肯为我们扮演纪录片导演。他会问我们问题，我们的导演，关于吊杆麦克风在哪里。雷恩饰演的德怀特被吊杆分散了注意力。
By the boom, oh my God. And he was saying, I really need you to move that. Ken says we can put it in your blind spot. And he says something like, I don't have a blind spot. I've been trained. So it's especially distracting for me. You need to understand that I'm highly trained. And it's just this little non-presentational conversation between Dwight and a documentarian
被吊杆，天哪。他说，我真的需要你把它移开。肯说我们可以把它放在你的盲点。他说，我没有盲点。我受过训练。所以这对我来说特别分散注意力。你需要明白我受过高度训练。这只是德怀特和纪录片导演之间那种非展示性的对话
about how to be Mike. I just want to say one thing. So many great things that were established in the pilot that you go on to see for years to come. Of course, one of the big ones is the Jim versus Dwight. Sort of their battle, right? And the pranks that Jim is going to do on Dwight. And I love that it just started out so simply with Dwight, like sort of their battle, right? And the pranks that Jim is gonna do on Dwight. And I love that it just started out so simply
关于如何成为迈克。我只想说一件事。试播集中确立了这么多伟大的东西，你会在未来几年里一直看到。当然，其中一个大主题是吉姆对阵德怀特。他们的战斗，对吧？还有吉姆要对德怀特做的恶作剧。我喜欢它开始得如此简单，德怀特，就像他们的战斗，对吧？还有吉姆要对德怀特做的恶作剧。我喜欢它开始得如此简单
with Dwight pushing all of Jim's papers back to his desk and then Jim making the pencil wall. That is just ridiculous. Well, that was borrowed from the British show. In the British show, they have the same desk war, but instead the Jim character piles up a bunch of boxes. He makes a box wall between the desks. And we did that when we filmed the pilot.
德怀特把吉姆所有的文件推回他的桌子，然后吉姆做了铅笔墙。那太荒谬了。嗯，那是从英国版借来的。在英国版里，他们有同样的桌子战争，但吉姆角色堆了一堆盒子。他在桌子之间做了一堵盒子墙。我们拍试播集时也做了那个。
We had Jim make a box wall. And in fact, you can see it in the background of conference room scenes. You can see a bunch of boxes piled up on Jim's desk. My lady, I'm going to go back and look. Later, when we got picked up, we reshot that scene and turned it into a little pencil thing.
我们让吉姆做了一堵盒子墙。事实上，你可以在会议室场景的背景里看到它。你可以看到吉姆桌子上堆了一堆盒子。我的天，我要回去看看。后来，当我们被续订时，我们重拍了那个场景，把它变成了铅笔墙。
And you can also see that Rain's hair is a little bit different in the pencil scene compared to the rest of the pilot. It's not as poofy. That's right. Exactly. Rain, as Dwight went through poofy hair phase, which looks like they used a little miniature
你还可以看到雷恩的头发在铅笔场景里和试播集的其余部分有点不同。没那么蓬松。没错。正是如此。雷恩饰演的德怀特经历过蓬松头发阶段，看起来他们用了一个小型的
like rolling brush to blow dry his hair. And then he went through flat parted down the middle phase. Well, Rain created the hairstyle for Dwight. And he said before that it is based on the hairstyle that he wore when he was a 16 year old boy. And so he did his own hair for the pilot. That makes me laugh. I've seen those photos of Rain.
滚刷来吹干他的头发。然后他经历了中间分缝的扁平阶段。嗯，雷恩创造了德怀特的造型。他说在那之前，这是基于他16岁时留的发型。所以他在试播集里自己弄了头发。这让我发笑。我见过雷恩的那些照片。
They're crazy. You wore your own clothes in the pilot. I wore my own clothes in the pilot. All right, so the last sort of thing I think we need to talk about is this big prank on Pam, quote unquote, the scene where Michael fake fires her. Well, he's so excited, because Jim has had a very successful prank,
它们太疯狂了。你在试播集里穿了自己的衣服。我穿了自己的衣服。好吧，最后一件事我想我们需要谈谈的是对帕姆的那个大恶作剧，所谓的迈克尔假装解雇她的场景。嗯，他太兴奋了，因为吉姆做了一个非常成功的恶作剧，
and Michael just, he wants to be in the spotlight. He wants to be the funny guy. So he's gonna show off for Ryan the temp, and he's gonna fake fire Pam. And it of course goes horribly wrong and she ends up in tears. And we shot that scene probably 30 times. Wow. And at the beginning of the scene,
迈克尔只是，他想成为焦点。他想成为那个有趣的人。所以他要在临时工瑞恩面前炫耀，他要假装解雇帕姆。当然，这变得非常糟糕，她最终泪流满面。我们拍那个场景大概拍了30次。哇。在场景开始时，
you can see everyone in the background kind of getting ready to leave for the day. And all those people had to wait for hours. They would have to start in the background and then we would do this whole scene. Oh, I know, Jenna, I know. I was there. I had to grab my jacket, my coat and my purse,
你可以看到背景里的每个人都在准备下班。所有那些人不得不等了几个小时。他们必须从背景开始，然后我们拍整个场景。哦，我知道，珍娜，我知道。我在那里。我不得不抓起我的夹克、外套和钱包，
put them down, my coat and my purse. I think of any scene in the entire history of The Office, this is the one that I've done the most because we did about 30 takes of it that day, but it was also my audition scene. This was one of my audition scenes. And so I auditioned for months for this role. I did that scene one time when I auditioned for the role of Pam,
放下它们，我的外套和钱包。我觉得在《办公室》整个历史上，这是我拍得最多的场景，因为那天我们拍了大约30次，但这也是我的试镜场景。这是我的试镜场景之一。所以我为这个角色试镜了几个月。我试镜帕姆这个角色时演过一次那个场景，
and I didn't get it. This is such a crazy, crazy bit of trivia. Yes, yes. Your first audition for The Office was for the role of Pam. Was for the role of Pam, and I wore a pink sweater. What? Was for the role of Pam and I wore a pink sweater. What? Yes. We both had the same instinct.
我没选上。这是一个非常疯狂的琐事。是的，是的。你为《办公室》的第一次试镜是帕姆这个角色。是帕姆这个角色，我穿了一件粉色毛衣。什么？是帕姆这个角色，我穿了一件粉色毛衣。什么？是的。我们都有同样的直觉。
Pam wore pink sweaters. I wore a pink sweater and my hair down and I was told to look, you know, like not too fancy, so I didn't do too much with my hair and makeup. I went in and I did the scene and it was for a room full of people, the producers. And when we got to the point where Michael fake fires you and you start to cry and you call him a jerk. Yeah. When I called him a jerk, everyone started to laugh. And I thought, I did something wrong.
帕姆穿粉色毛衣。我穿了一件粉色毛衣，头发披着，我被告知看起来，你知道，不要太时髦，所以我没在头发和妆容上做太多。我进去演了那个场景，房间里坐满了人，制片人们。当我们演到迈克尔假装解雇你，你开始哭，叫他混蛋时。是的。当我叫他混蛋时，每个人都开始笑。我心想，我做错了什么。
I don't think they're supposed to laugh at this moment. And of course, like Jenna, you were so brilliant because you brought such a vulnerability to Pam that even though this job sucks and she hates it, she needs it. She needs this crappy job. And you really felt her in that moment. You just, my heart broke for her. And when you call him a jerk, it's just like you're really wounded. And it checks Michael in his place of like,
我觉得他们不应该在这个时候笑。当然，像珍娜一样，你表现得非常出色，因为你为帕姆带来了那种脆弱感，即使这份工作很糟糕，她很讨厌它，但她需要它。她需要这份烂工作。在那一刻，你真的让人感同身受。我的心都为她碎了。当你叫他混蛋时，就好像你真的受伤了。这让迈克尔意识到，
that wasn't cool. Right? Well, it's funny because this was a somewhat controversial scene about whether or not it should be included. When Ricky and Steven were counseling Greg, I understand that they told him that he should consider cutting this scene because they said that it's in their pilot and they felt like they always had to fight to come back from it, that it made the boss a little too mean
那样做并不酷。对吧？嗯，很有趣，因为这是一个颇具争议的场景，关于是否应该保留它。当瑞奇和史蒂文在给格雷格提建议时，我听说他们告诉他应该考虑删掉这个场景，因为他们说这是在试播集中，他们觉得总是要费力去挽回这个形象，这让老板显得有点太刻薄了，
and so later they really leaned into his buffoonery. But Greg fought to keep it in. He thought, no, we're going to try it. We're going to let her cry. We're going to let Michael be mean to her. Now there was an alt line where I think that sometimes instead of saying you're a jerk, I said you're a sad little man. And they said that's too harsh. That's harsh. You can't come back from that. That is harsh. So here's a little fun tidbit, Jenna. Another tidbit, not a fast fact. A tidbit from Angela Kinsey. When Michael wants to prank Pam in front of Ryan the temp, Michael as Steve turns to Ryan, BJ, and says, have you
所以后来他们真的倾向于表现他的滑稽。但格雷格坚持要保留它。他想，不，我们要试一试。我们要让她哭。我们要让迈克尔对她刻薄。现在有一个备选台词，我想有时我不说“你是个混蛋”，而是说“你是个可悲的小男人”。他们说那太刺耳了。那太刺耳了。你无法从那句话中挽回形象。那确实很刺耳。所以这里有一个有趣的小花絮，珍娜。另一个花絮，不是快讯。来自安吉拉·金赛的花絮。当迈克尔想在临时工瑞安面前捉弄帕姆时，迈克尔（史蒂夫饰）转向瑞安（BJ饰）说，你
ever seen, you know, do you like prank shows? Have you ever seen Punk'd? BJ was on Punk'd. He was on Punk'd. He was on season two of Punk'd. So I thought that was a nice little nod that he's looking at someone who was on Punk'd and says, do you like Punk'd? And BJ's like, yeah, like is Ryan. Anyway, that's a Kinsey tidbit for you. So the end of this episode, Pam has been crying and Jim wants to cheer her up. So he puts Michael's world's best boss mug in Jell-O. Now, this was exclusive to our show. Yes.
见过吗，你知道，你喜欢恶作剧节目吗？你看过《整蛊总动员》吗？BJ上过《整蛊总动员》。他上过。他参加了《整蛊总动员》第二季。所以我认为这是一个很好的小致敬，他看着一个上过《整蛊总动员》的人，然后问，你喜欢《整蛊总动员》吗？BJ说，是的，就像瑞安一样。总之，这就是给你们的金赛花絮。所以这一集的结尾，帕姆一直在哭，吉姆想让她振作起来。于是他把迈克尔的“世界最佳老板”马克杯放进了果冻里。这可是我们剧集的独家内容。是的。
So the whole- It's not in the BBC version. That's right. The mug itself is set up in an early talking head. And then this convention of ending the episode with Jim doing something sweet for Pam by putting the mug in Jell-O. That was all Greg Daniel's idea.
所以整个……BBC版本里没有这个。没错。马克杯本身在早期的谈话片段中就出现了。然后以吉姆通过把马克杯放进果冻里为帕姆做点贴心事来结束这一集的惯例。这全是格雷格·丹尼尔斯的主意。
And I think it's such a sweet way to end the show. Yeah. Yeah, and so, and now, and then of course, the iconic World's Best. We just did it! We did it. We did it. We did our first podcast.
我觉得这是结束这一集非常贴心的方式。是的。是的，然后，当然，标志性的“世界最佳”。我们刚刚做到了！我们做到了。我们做到了。我们完成了我们的第一个播客。
You guys, we really, we were really nervous. You guys, we were really nervous. We actually, in the middle of doing this, I was getting so nervous that Angela made us turn off the microphones and have a dance party. I did. To loosen me up. I did, I put on Taylor Swift's paper rings and I made her dance around and get out of her head.
伙计们，我们真的，我们真的很紧张。伙计们，我们真的很紧张。实际上，在做这个的过程中，我变得非常紧张，以至于安吉拉让我们关掉麦克风，跳了一场舞。我确实这么做了。为了让我放松下来。我确实这么做了，我放了泰勒·斯威夫特的《Paper Rings》，我让她跳舞，让她从那种状态中走出来。
I was spiraling. You were, but here's the thing. This is why we're nervous. It's because the show means so much to us, and we are new, obviously, to the podcast scene, and your support has been overwhelming. I literally teared up when we let you guys know we were doing a podcast, and just the immediate support
我当时快崩溃了。你是，但重点是。这就是我们紧张的原因。因为这部剧对我们意义重大，而且我们显然是播客界的新人，你们的支持让我们受宠若惊。当我们告诉你们我们要录制播客时，我真的热泪盈眶，仅仅是那种即时的支持
from all of you out there, I got a little emotional. Me too. So I just thank you guys so much, and just know how much it means to us that this show that is so special to us keeps finding an audience. It just really means the world to us. It's changed our lives. Forever.
来自你们所有人的支持，我有点激动。我也是。所以我真的非常感谢你们，要知道这部对我们如此特别的剧集能不断找到观众，这对我们意义重大。这真的对我们来说意味着全世界。它永远改变了我们的生活。
Yeah. So thank you. Thank you guys. All right. First one. Next week, since we're going in order, we're going to be talking about Diversity Day. So much fun. So if you want to watch it with us, just watch Diversity Day by next Wednesday and then we'll talk about it. Yeah, and you hear that? That's our theme music by my neighbor,
是的。所以谢谢你们。谢谢你们。好了。第一个完成了。下周，因为我们是按顺序来的，我们将讨论“多元化日”。太有趣了。所以如果你想和我们一起看，就在下周三之前看完“多元化日”，然后我们再讨论它。是的，你听到了吗？那是我的邻居创作的主题音乐，
Creed Bratton. It's his song, Rubber Tree, with Mr. Ed Helms on banjo. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fischer and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva. Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise--Berman and Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil.
克里德·布拉顿。这是他的歌《Rubber Tree》，由埃德·赫尔姆斯先生演奏班卓琴。感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作创作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和助理制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。
Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Breton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。